Mariah Carey is hiding her pain  since she and fiance James Packer split  the diva has been hitting the town  spotted out to dinner several times in  recent days sometimes accompanied by her  sexy backup dancer Bryan Tanaka Sunday  night she was with her twins Munro and  Moroccan and ex Nick Cannon the family  headed to Jessica Biel's kid-friendly  West Hollywood restaurant oh fudge but a  source tells e.t quote Mariah is  traumatized by all of this but is  putting on a brave face she never meant  to fall for James interestingly Kerry  has still some time has been wearing her  massive engagement ring from billionaire  Packer though she has been switching it  between her left and right hands she was  wearing it Sunday night but not on  Saturday Kerry and Packer got engaged in  January  my  you